[Music]  of all the jungle cruises you could take  in the amazon  this one is undoubtedly the cheapest  but also the most thrilling heads up  coming through  look out  marauders  natives  ladies and gentlemen the moment you've  all been waiting for  the backside of water  steve's wonder of the world  anjana frankie mr nila please don't call  me that i'm going to keep your engine i  got my money  then you'll get it back frank gives me  money  [Music]  miss milo frank owes me money not a good  time my brother and i are  i gotta be honest it's not a fun  vacation  are you gonna beg me to turn back  10 000 to bring you there live dead it's  15 000.  why should i pay more debt  dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot  harder lady here we go  you